- [Instructor] A buffer solution consists
of a significant amount of a weak acid
and its conjugate base.
Let's say we have a generic weak acid, HA,
and its conjugate base, A-.
And we're gonna use some
particulate diagrams
to try to understand how buffers work.
So for our first particulate diagram,
let's count out how many
particles we have of each.
So first let's count how many HAs we have.
So there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 HAs,
and there's also, for A-,
there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 A minuses.
And when looking at a
particulate diagram of a buffer,
usually water molecules
are omitted for clarity.
And also keep in mind that
this particulate diagram
is just meant to represent a
small portion of the solution,
so we can get an idea
about what's happening
in the entire solution.
Also notice that like water molecules,
cations are also left out
of the particulate diagram.
So we have five HA particles
and five A- particles
in our aqueous solution.
Having equal amounts of a weak
acid and its conjugate base
is a good buffer solution.
Let's see what happens
to the buffer solution
if we add in a small amount of acid.
So here I'm drawing in an H+ ion,
and let's think about adding this H+ ion
to our buffer solution.
When the H+ ion is added to the solution,
the base that is present
will react with the H+ ion
to neutralize it.
So the added H+ reacts with A- to form HA.
So for the particulate diagrams,
this added H+ is going to react
with one of the A minuses
present in the buffer solution.
So the H+ and the A- form an HA.
So we're gonna go from
five HAs to six HAs.
So let's look at this next
particulate diagram here.
We can see there are now
six HAs in the solution,
so let me write down six here.
And since we started with five,
A minuses and we lost one,
we should have only four
A minuses in solution now.
So let's write down a four here.
So you started off with
five HAs and five A minuses,
and upon the addition of
a small amount of acid,
the acid was neutralized by
the base that was present,
and we formed six HAs and four A minuses.
So a buffer solution
resists changes in pH.
So the added H+ was neutralized
by the presence of the base.
If the buffer solution
had not been present,
if we just had some water
and we added some H+,
the pH would have changed dramatically.
One way to write the acid-base
neutralization reaction
that occurred is to write
H+ plus A- goes to HA.
However, since H3O+ and H+
are used interchangeably in chemistry,
we could have also written
the net ionic equation
as H3O+ plus A- goes to HA and H2O.
Next, let's go back to our
middle particulate diagram
with five HA and five A-.
And this time let's try
to add some hydroxide ions
to the solution.
So think about,
let me go ahead and draw an arrow here,
so we're gonna add a small amount of base
to our buffer solution.
The hydroxide anion will
react with the weak acid
that is present, HA, to form H2O and A-.
So for the particulate diagrams,
we can think about this OH-
reacting with one of the HAs
to form H2O and an A-.
Since we're using up one of the HAs,
we're gonna go from five
HAs down to four HAs.
So let me write down here, four HAs.
And when this HA reacts,
it's gonna turn into an A-.
So we're gonna go from
five A minuses up to six.
So let's count them over here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So let's write in six A minuses.
If there is no buffer present
and we're just adding
hydroxide anions to water,
the pH would change dramatically.
However, with a buffer present,
since there is a weak acid, HA, present
to neutralize the added hydroxide anions,
the buffer solution
resists a change to the pH.
So let's summarize how
buffer solutions work.
If we add a small amount of an acid, H+,
to a buffer solution,
the conjugate base that's present, A-,
neutralizes the added acid.
Therefore, the buffer solution
resists a change in pH.
And if we add a small amount of a base,
the weak acid that's present
will neutralize the hydroxide anions.
Therefore, the buffer solution
resists a change in pH.
Let's say we have an aqueous
solution of acetic acid
and an aqueous solution of sodium acetate.
And let's say we have
equal moles of acetic acid
and of sodium acetate.
Mixing these two solutions together
would form a buffer solution.
To understand why this
forms a buffer solution,
let's first think about acetic acid.
Acetic acid is a weak acid
and only partially ionizes
in aqueous solution.
Therefore, in aqueous solution,
we have mostly acetic acid, CH3COOH.
Sodium acetate is a soluble salt
and it dissociates completely
in aqueous solution.
Therefore, in aqueous solution,
we have sodium cations and
acetate anions, CH3COO-.
The acetate anion is the
conjugate base to acetic acid.
Therefore, in aqueous solution,
we have a weak acid
and its conjugate base,
and so we have a buffer solution.
If we try adding a small amount of acid
to the buffer solution,
the conjugate base
that's present will react
with the acid and neutralize it.
So in the balanced net ionic equation,
the added acid hydronium ion, H3O+,
reacts with the acetate anion
to form acetic acid and water.
So the added hydronium
ion was neutralized,
and the buffer has resisted
a dramatic change in pH.
If we try adding a small amount of base
to the buffer solution,
the weak acid that is present
will neutralize the added base.
So in the balanced net ionic equation,
hydroxide anions react with acetic acid
to form the acetate anion and water.
So the added base was neutralized.
So to summarize,
the acetic acid-acetate buffer system
resists dramatic changes in pH
when small amounts of
acid or base are added.
And I just noticed,
I forgot to include the
L for liquid for water
in the balanced net ionic equations.